we're going to be analyzing a fellow who
criticized the scientific method the
genuine real scientific method and we're
going to analyze some of the things he
said about the scientific method and
it's important because a lot of people
out there have the same idea that he has
or ideas in general you know that
scientific method is doing fine which we
call the mathematical method because all
explanations are magical for invisible
and intangible entities and phenomena
and so
you know uh we don't think that's
science
okay and there has been no improvement
in the last 2500 years
in our understanding of gravity in our
understanding not 2 500 but a little
less than that in our understanding of
magnetism electricity the atom and uh
gravity um this one um
i don't find this one anyways the deal
is that um
i'm saying that we haven't made any
progress whatsoever
in our understanding of the invisible
and intangible
entities and mechanisms that mother
nature uses daily
you know you drop a pen to the floor
why does it fall to the floor
after 2500 years not a single
mathematician on planet earth can tell
you the answer can give you an answer
and the reason is very clear
they can't see or touch
whatever serves as a mediator
and so they simulate their physical
interpretations with concepts with
abstract mathematical concepts and
people say oh i understood when they did
not understand anything you should be
able to explain gravity the way you
explain the workings of a car or
or whatever any physical mechanism and
that's not the case they do not explain
the mechanism
anyways this fellow
attacked certain aspects of the theory
and of the scientific method that we
have and of course
by
indirectly the theory right based on it
and um
so this is where we start we start with
what he had to say this time we're going
to be analyzing a couple points that he
said and here it goes give me a second
here and i'll turn it on there we go
listen to what he's got to say about
what he's uh going to be criticizing
what he's saying that
about gravity especially
these are the questions and issues to be
resolved in this
rejoinder have the mathematicians made
any progress in men's understanding of
gravity in the last 400 years
does the theory of relativity explain
how gravity works
to act like there has been no new
discoveries in the last 400 years about
gravity is just plain wrong the theories
of relativity have definitely played a
part in furthering our understanding of
gravity
okay so that's the issue
and uh we'll concentrate mainly on the
last 400 years i'm saying that in 2500
years we haven't figured it out but 400
if we go with our last 400 years i think
we're doing fine we're going to be
answering the question okay let's see
what newton had to say about gravity
what his
uh tremendous knowledge was about
gravity this is newton okay this is out
of principia out of his skull okay here
it goes he says hitherto we have
explained the phenomena of the heavens
and our and of our sea by the power of
gravity but have not yet assigned the
cause of this power
it must proceed from a cause that
penetrates to the very centers of the
sun and planets without suffering the
least diminution of its force
thereto i have not been able to discover
the cause of those properties of gravity
from phenomena and i framed no
hypothesis his famous
uh
saying you know he had no theory no
explanation for how gravity works and he
says for whatever is not deduced from
the phenomena is to be called a a
hypothesis and hypothesis whether
metaphysical or physical whether of a
qualities or mechanical have no place in
experimental philosophy meaning uh
what they thought was science and what
still remains to be
to this day is considered to be science
experiments experiments or experimental
philosophy as he called it then and the
issue there is he's not going to be able
to
detect uh the mechanism of invisible
intangible gravity uh by doing an
experiment and this is where they failed
right there and he continued says it is
enough that gravity does really exist
well we don't know about this
exist word because he hasn't defined it
and no one has in the last 2 500 years
so we don't know what he means when he
says that gravity does exist okay what
does he mean by that does god exist what
does he mean by that does the chair
exist what does he mean by that unless
we define the word exist we have no idea
what he just said
and act according to the laws which
we have explained and abundantly serves
to account for all the motions of the
celestial bodies and of our sea
okay so this is the issue the issue is
that he had no clue how gravity worked
so you can say that at least 400 years
ago it was probably the top honcho then
17th century he had no clue okay he's
staying at there you know uh fingo nun
hypothesis or hypothesis non-fingo what
are those two and meaning i framed no
hypothesis he had no clue how it worked
he he said yeah there's an effect called
gravity and that pulls on the seas and
whatever but he doesn't know how that
works how it's done through space in
other words right okay so let's uh fast
forward let's go to
uh
what we have uh more recently in the
20th century we had a fellow his name
was albert einstein and he's credited
today with having discovered gravity in
fact this fellow says that general
relativity uh explained gravity warpage
of space warpage of time one of those
two or both
and uh so let's see what einstein had to
say about it towards the end of his life
you know if you would have caught
einstein when he was 26 when he wrote
his uh first uh four papers that he
published in 1905 well he was a hot head
you know
uh
he knew everything but when he was about
to die in the 50s he became suddenly a
very ignorant man and here you see why
he these are his words by the way okay
okay and so here it is
this is uh
you can see the dates there 54 and 49
all these 50 years of conscious brooding
have brought me no nearer to the answer
to the question what are like quanta
nowadays every time dick and harry
thinks he knows it but he is mistaken
i consider it quite possible that
physics cannot be based on the field
concept
in other words on continuous structures
in that case nothing remains of my
entire castle in the air gravitation
theory included and of the rest of
modern physics
and of course um they pushed him aside
over there in princeton where he was
working the last few years of his life
and he wrote these couple letters there
also he says i have become an obstinate
heretic in the eyes of my colleagues
because he did not believe in quantum
mechanics and he was believing even in
general relativity anymore he became an
atheist in his own religion
and then he says i'm generally regarded
as a sort of petrified object rendered
blind and deaf by the years
einstein became a piece of furniture
towards the end of the life his life
nobody paid any attention to him he was
put in a corner there giving a big
salary because he was such a big name
and i guess he did more in that sense
for the uh princeton than princeton did
for him in the sense that hey we got
einstein here you know and that was all
it was worth
uh he he died not understanding how
gravity works let alone quantum
mechanics which he didn't believe in uh
you know in his entire life
so this is how it ends uh pretty much
because everybody now glorifies einstein
says oh einstein yeah what did he do for
science and he said well he invented uh
warp time
that's what he did he introduced warp
time now we do everything with mark time
okay and so here's what time folks this
is what this is einstein's contribution
to science
in a nutshell okay we have mass a
concept mathematical concept and it
bends this sheet this uh i guess
trampoline or canvas or whatever you
want to call it they call it a fabric
and what is that fabric made out of is
it made out of wool uh nylon what is
that a rubber band maybe
no those lines that you see stretching
there those are lines of time
and space but we're going to discard
space here we're interested in saying
that what he's doing he's bending time
and how do you explain gravity by
bending time i mean that's okay to
describe that mathematically and say
look you know every time there's uh this
issue with gravity time uh seems to run
slower in some clocks that are out there
and faster over here and whatever
yeah that's that's fine those are
descriptions
we're talking about what is the
mechanism of gravity why doesn't the
earth fly out of the solar system why
does the moon fly out of the solar
system or fall towards the sun
you know so that's the physical
mechanism of what we're trying to get to
and of course this is ridiculous this is
this is absolutely poppy got nonsense
this is but this is what people believe
today including this fellow okay so you
know i think he has a call to laugh at
people who laugh at that
what you just saw
yeah that is ridiculous nonsense okay
you don't say that the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system because time is
warped that's
a ridiculous nonsense it has no validity
whatsoever in science maybe at the
looney asylum but not in science
okay um
so some people
came over and this is pertinent to what
this fellow said and and they criticized
what i said and i said a little i think
i said a little something a little
differently but um
it was taken out of context
and i was referring to the fact to the
fact that in 2500 years no one has
figured out gravity or uh magnetism or
anything of that nature you know the
invisible things and you can see here
how everybody you know went off on a
tangent and they started talking about
something else one fellow says
uh first repeats what i said so i'm
saying that we have made no progress in
the last 2 500 years what was i talking
about gravity specifically you know the
mechanism of gravity understanding what
the mechanism is what is he said says
the guy streaming audio and video to the
entire world what is he talking about
technology
and so again these people don't even pay
attention to what's going on
here's another fellow he says i'm saying
that we have made no progress in the
last 2 500 years and what is the answer
he says the fact that we can cure
illnesses which were death sentence uh
just 200 years ago achieved flight split
the atom put humans on the moon sent
spacecraft to every other planet within
our solar system and a whole host of
other accomplishments discredits this
assertion completely your opinion
remains just that without supporting
evidence so not only he's also
introducing technology or talking about
technology which had nothing to do with
what i was talking about but on top of
that he says you need evidence
and uh what evidence for what is
evidence there to
recruit people to convince them to
persuade them
what's the purpose of evidence
you know what evidence can i provide for
a mechanism that i'm just explaining how
gravity works you know i just want to
explain why the spoon falls to the floor
okay if i want to explain that whatever
am i going to present whatever do you
want that's the question what evidence
would convince you
i mean uh what am i supposed to do you
know tell me and i'll present the
evidence that will convince you so no
evidence plays no role in science
absolutely not plays a role only in
religion in sunday school then you need
evidence because you're going to be
convincing people you're going to try to
persuade them to believe like you do
that's not what we do in science it says
we explain a mechanism objectively so
that people understand and that's where
science ends what continues after that
is opinion belief
you know religion
okay and yeah another foul also said
something similar aren't these robes
just also just a concept no a rope is
not a concept
this is not a concept this is a physical
object okay and that's why you need to
define what a concept is and what an
object is
and he says uh what's the supposed
difference to former theories this is
just switching out words scientific
method isn't perfect but it provides
helpful tools to predict things and
construct what new technology
if your theory or hypothesis doesn't
predict anything it's pretty much
useless now no science is useless
science has no use whatsoever hopefully
okay science is only about explaining
okay now if that helps you in some way
in your
dark basement and you can
develop some device because of some
understanding in science well more power
to you but that's not the goal of
science science has nothing at all to do
with technology okay science is only
about explaining how the universe works
and that's where we have made no
progress in twenty five hundred years no
none whatsoever
okay none whatsoever not a single
mathematician out there who calls
themselves a phys
physicist mathematical physicist right
uh can explain to you how gravity works
or how magnetism works or how
electricity works they cannot because as
soon as they explain something you know
they're going to be in deep trouble
because they're going to explain it
either with concepts which is irrational
you can't explain a mechanism with
concepts and then the other part is that
you know they explain it with particles
and the problem with particles assuming
they were real particles which they
ain't okay by the way but assuming they
were real particles you know what's
known as classical particles how do you
explain attraction with particles
and you have to do you know a taller
make explanation and somehow push
the the two objects together from the
outside and maybe take some stuff from
the inside you know they go through all
these weird
processes to explain pull via push
it don't work that way mother nature
hopefully has a mechanism for pull and
the only way you can pull is putting
something between the two objects okay
and you know i i have explained you can
do this at home you know can i explain
that you know you have two magnets those
two round ones there right and again
don't take my word for it do it at home
on your own right and you can feel that
there's there's nothing pushing on my
hands from the outside you can feel that
there's a tug already from the inside
and don't take my word for it and go
prove it to yourself the tug is from the
inside and if it's from the inside you
only have two choices you either put
something there that's there that you
can't see or touch
or you do it with magic okay
and magic involves using what uh
concepts mathematical concepts which
they introduce in lieu of objects
and that's the story of for today for
that one